INTERVIEWER: So this is the
"Indie Game, The Movie" panel.
And we have here Lisanne Pajot
and James Swirsky.
Or actually, [INAUDIBLE]
in Polish.
So let's just kind of
kind of see what
the movie's all about.
[BEGIN VIDEO PLAYBACK]
TOMMY REFENES: I am determined
to make video games, and I
make video games
because I can.
PHIL FISH: I mean, it's the sum
total of every expressive
medium of all times,
made interactive.
Like how is that not--
it's awesome.
EDMUND MCMILLEN: My whole career
has been me trying to
find new ways to communicate
with people, because I
desperately want to communicate
with people, but I
don't want the messy interaction
of having to make
friends and talk to
people, because I
probably don't like them.
PHIL FISH: And it's
not just the game.
Like, it's--
I'm so closely attached to it,
this is my identity, is "FEZ."
I'm Guy Making "FEZ."
That's about it.
JONATHAN BLOW: Making it was
about, let me take my deepest
flaws and vulnerabilities and
put them in the game.
PHIL FISH: I'm on the line.
Me.
Like my name, my career.
If this fails, I don't think
I'll work in games again.
EDMUND MCMILLEN: I'm like in a
fucking concentration camp.
If you can't get the work done,
then the past two years
are basically worth nothing.
No pressure.
PHIL FISH: All we've
been doing for four
years, is look at this.
Like this close.
Like--
you can't see anything else.
You don't even see the mistakes
in it anymore.
TOMMY REFENES: What
the fuck is that?
[SHOUTS AND LAUGHS]
PHIL FISH: Damn it!
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
INTERVIEWER: Cool.
So I'm curious, first of all--
so I love the movie.
I've watched it three
times by now.
And every time, I kind of
want to do something.
First time, I decided I should
make a documentary, because
it's apparently very easy, and
we're going to hear about it.
The second one, I wanted
to write an indie game.
And the third time, I haven't
really processed it yet,
because it was two days ago.
But we'll see.
But I'm curious, well, first of
all, how did it all start?
How did you get the idea?
JAMES SWIRSKY: Cool.
It all kind of started with--
prior to doing the movie,
we had a kind of
commercial/corporate video gig,
and we kind of worked on
that for about the last
seven years or so.
And we actually got hired by the
Canadian government to do
a series of profiles on
Winnipeg tech stories.
And one of them was on this guy
Alec Holowka, who along
with Derek Yu made this great
game called "Aquaria" that won
the biggest prize you could
possibly win in independent
gaming back in 2007, I think.
And we got tasked with making
this short, little five-minute
piece on it.
And we thought it was
going to be this
kind of, fluffy, light--
look, I made a game.
Isn't that cool?
Type of video.
And ultimately, we did
make that video.
But the process of making that
video and talking to Alec, the
story was just so much more.
It was kind of this story about
this guy who thought he
was making one game, and then
ended up with this completely
different game that reflected
all this stuff that he was
going through this life
while making the game.
It became darker and
more emotional.
It was just, his experience
making the game was completely
tied to the game itself.
And so it was this whole idea
of games being used as story
or expression that
was new to us.
It was not a new idea, but it
was kind of something new to
us, like seeing someone in
their own game so much.
And then shortly after that,
we went down to the Game
Developers Conference, which
we had been going to for
various reasons for
a couple of years.
And we were hanging around the
Independent Games Summit.
And we just kept on hearing
story after story of very
similar things.
Like people pouring everything
they had into their game, and
these really dramatic
dev cycles.
And we thought to ourselves, if
we can get that in a movie,
if we can get that on tape, or
just even a semblance of that,
that's something that we
would love to watch.
And then we kind of looked
around for video-game design
documentaries, and there
were hardly any.
There were very few.
I think "Get Lamp," by Jason
Scott, was the only one I
could find.
And we thought, this
needs to exist.
Why hasn't someone
told this story?
There needs to be a "Helvetica"
or "Objectified"
of video games.
And we set out kind of with
the idea of making that.
In the end, we made something
quite different.
But that was kind of our first
impetus of it, is Alec leading
to GDC, leading to something
needs to exist--
let's make it.
INTERVIEWER: And as far as I
remember, your original idea
for the movie-- and you actually
had a cut of some
sort that turned out to be
something completely different
than what we can see today.
So was it kind of the same story
for you, that you made a
movie and then you realized
you'd have to remake it again,
just to say something
different.
LISANNE PAJOT: Yeah.
We started out interviewing lots
of different developers.
Because we really didn't know
where this land, or we didn't
really know what it was.
We knew that it was going to be
a film about indie games,
and so we called it "Indie
Game, The Movie" on,
like, the first day.
JAMES SWIRSKY: It was
a working title.
LISANNE PAJOT: It was
just this project.
And yeah, so we thought the film
would involve a lot more
developers, and we interviewed
a lot of people.
But throughout the process, we
ended up spending more and
more time with the creators of
the three main game, "Super
Meat Boy," "Fez," and "Braid."
And the way we met these people
were, we were like,
hey, Alec, who should
we talk to?
And that's sort of
how it started.
And we started reaching out to
people and talking to people
that were in the process of
making games, but a lot had
already made their games.
And we thought the film would be
this sort of marriage of a
story, like, someone making and
releasing a game, and then
in between, you'd jump off to
all these different people
that had made games and you'd
find out more about them, and
more about the process.
But it just turned into more
of a journey film following
these three games.
So it was very different.
Our first cut of the film was
about three hours long and
really awful.
It just wasn't a good movie.
INTERVIEWER: Are you
going to include it
on the DVD or Blu-ray?
LISANNE PAJOT: Yeah, we're
going to cut it
apart and make it better.
JAMES SWIRSKY: Make it
more digestible.
LISANNE PAJOT: On the
special edition.
But yeah, no, the project
really sort of morphed.
We were discovering what the
movie was throughout.
The first thing that we had done
was we actually went down
to Santa Cruz, where we're
staying right now, and we
filmed with Edmund and Tommy
from "Super Meat Boy."
And we shot this little piece
and we put it up on the web in
May 2010, on Kickstarter.
And this was early days
for Kickstarter.
Not many people were using it.
And we made our goal, which was
a modest goal of $15,000
in less than two days.
And to us, that was
a huge thing.
It was a life-changing moment
to have all these people
around the world, like 300
people, decide that they
wanted to support this film.
And it sounds small, but to
us as two filmmakers from
Winnipeg, it was huge.
And that's what made
us decide to--
it sounds kind of silly now.
It made us decide to give up our
work and take this on it
as a goal for the next year.
We thought it would take a
year to make the film.
It ended up taking two years.
INTERVIEWER: So Kickstarter
was one of the kind of
interesting aspects of
your project, right?
And you were really, really open
about the whole process
throughout the making
of the movie.
You, I think, posted 90 minutes
worth of video as you
were working on it.
Which by then, like, why would
you ever watch the movie, if
you already saw 90 minutes
of video, right?
JAMES SWIRSKY: That's what
a lot of film people
were saying to us.
They're like, oh, you're
giving away
all your DVD extras.
What are you doing?
LISANNE PAJOT: Yeah,
it was 90 minutes.
But only five minutes are
actually in the movie.
So it was all extras.
Yeah, it's kind of a problem.
Yeah, we could make about
20 movies out of
the footage we recorded.
We still have--
we shot 300 hours.
It was kind of silly.
Like we just kept shooting.
We're still shooting.
JAMES SWIRSKY: Yeah,
yeah, yeah.
But in a good way, I think,
as we discovered the movie
through that process.
We're finding, with
documentaries, it's really
easy to call it wasted effort.
We've done and edited and shot
so many things that just
ultimately wasn't right
for the movie.
But you have to kind of explore
those stories and
those characters and see if
those techniques work.
And yeah, it's weird when you
look at all the stuff that
didn't make it into the movie.
It's a whole bunch of
expended effort.
But I think it made for
a better movie.
LISANNE PAJOT: Yeah.
So we did share a lot.
So we put out all these little
pieces of things that were,
like, oh, this won't make
it in the movie.
Let's just cut something from
the hotel where we're shooting
and put it up on the internet.
And we just wanted to share as
much as we could, because we
felt this immense amount
of responsibility
to these 300 people.
And then that's community
grew over the course
of making the film.
And that's really what gave us
a lot of confidence to move
forward, and be like, yeah,
this is a good idea.
JAMES SWIRSKY: We were also
really inspired by what indie
game developers themselves were
doing at the time, like
doing things like pre-orders and
open betas and just being
really painfully honest about
where their game's at and
where their game's heading.
And we saw all these great
examples of people building up
their audiences even before
their game was released, even
a long time before their
game was released.
And that kept the audience
engaged and kept them engaged,
and I just really liked the idea
of working that way, of
kind of sharing about the movie
as we're making it.
And so we embraced that
wholeheartedly, and put out
all this content and let people
know where we were
going with it.
And it had, for the
most, I think,
really positive effects.
It got people excited and we hit
the ground running when it
came time, to June.
We didn't have to bring a whole
bunch of people up to
speed as to what we were doing,
and I think we probably
saved a lot of marketing
dollars that way.
It does have this weird effect
of enhancing this weird time
warp that happens on the
internet when you're kind of
paying attention to something
for a long time.
You know, if you watch something
on the internet for
like a year, it seems like three
years or four years.
And there's a weird kind
of dog-year phenomenon.
So people, even though they had
only been paying attention
for eight months, it felt
like three years.
So doing it again, we'd probably
manage it a little
bit different.
But not too, too different.
INTERVIEWER: And so what
happened afterwards?
I think you had another
Kickstarter campaign.
And then all sorts of wonderful
things started happening.
I remember you had a blog post
eventually chronicling the
timeline of the movie, and it's
just amazing, trying to
just read that, what kind of
things happened afterwards.
So I was curious if you
can recap that for us.
LISANNE PAJOT: Yeah.
When you're work on a project
like this, it's all-consuming,
and it was really all-consuming
to us.
But when we looked back at the
timeline, there was something
significant that happened,
like, every two weeks.
Which-- we're kind of tired.
But we did another Kickstarter
campaign because the film had
transformed into something
different.
We felt like at first it would
be this film that we would put
out on the internet and
people would like, and
that would be that.
But then it sort of grew into
something that we could see as
a theatrical film, that we
could put in theaters.
And it had a story and it
was tense and emotional.
And so we needed a bit more
money to finish it.
Because basically, $23,000 was
our budget and just our time.
James and I did all the shooting
and the editing and
all the stuff ourselves.
So it was just time
that we needed.
But at that point, we
had to bring on--
we brought on a composer and
we did do some color
correction and things
like that.
So we appealed to the community
again, and by this
time, there was more people
following the project.
INTERVIEWER: This is
the second page.
LISANNE PAJOT: Yeah.
And then we made
that in a day.
And so that--
that was shocking.
INTERVIEWER: So you should have
gone with a third one and
a fourth one.
LISANNE PAJOT: Yeah, just
keep delaying it.
No, but that was an awesome vote
of confidence, again, and
made us feel really good, and
gave us enough money to pay a
composer and finish the movie.
INTERVIEWER: So the soundtrack
is about the only thing you
were not really responsible
for yourselves, right?
LISANNE PAJOT: Yeah, and the 5.1
mixing, we got a company
to do that.
INTERVIEWER: And there was also
an interesting kind of
indie game-ish story, right?
Finding the composer.
JAMES SWIRSKY: Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
Basically when we were kind of
making the movie and editing
it, I was playing this game,
"Sword & Sorcery" by Capybara,
a Super Brothers game.
And the music in that
game is amazing.
It's done by a guy, Jim Guthrie,
who's also Canadian.
And we kind of kept on going
back and forth, because we
were scoring the movie
with temp music--
LISANNE PAJOT: With "The
Social Network."
JAMES SWIRSKY: Yeah.
Yeah.
And we'd never worked with a
composer before, so we didn't
really know how to
go about this.
And so we thought, wouldn't it
be amazing if the guy who did
this game, Jim Guthrie,
if he did our music?
So we shot him an email,
thinking that there's no way
he's going to do this.
Because he's actually a
rock star in Canada.
LISANNE PAJOT: He has
the equivalent
of a Grammy in Canada.
JAMES SWIRSKY: A Juno.
LISANNE PAJOT: Yeah.
So we were just, like, uh, he's
never going to reply.
Let's just email him anyway.
And within like 10 hours, he
said yeah, let's do it.
And he had watched the
first cut the film.
INTERVIEWER: We actually have
his email right here.
JAMES SWIRSKY: Yeah.
INTERVIEWER: Because at
Google, we kind of--
no, you had it on your
[INAUDIBLE].
[LAUGHTER]
JAMES SWIRSKY: Yeah.
This was the very first feedback
we got from a rough
cut of the film.
Not the three-hour cut, but this
was the first time anyone
had seen it.
And this was huge for us.
Not only was it the first time
we got positive feedback, and
it had fucks and everything--
like he was excited.
And yeah--
INTERVIEWER: That's how you
know it's true, right?
JAMES SWIRSKY: Yeah, completely,
because there's
four exclamation points.
Yeah.
And so it was amazing.
Not only that, but it was the
guy that we really, really,
really wanted to work with.
And then from there, he just
started making music.
And he made all the music for
the movie in about two months,
maybe even a little
less than that.
LISANNE PAJOT: Like
five weeks.
JAMES SWIRSKY: It was a crazy
crunch, 'cause we were.
LISANNE PAJOT: He did
80 minutes of new
music in five weeks.
He works crazy.
He doesn't really sleep.
He only sleeps four
hours a day.
So it worked out for us.
JAMES SWIRSKY: And everything
he gave us was just perfect
and fantastic and took the
movie in places we didn't
think it would.
And it was like a dream
experience with a composer.
LISANNE PAJOT: Now it's out
as an album online.
jimguthrie.org.
JAMES SWIRSKY: Jim
Guthrie, yeah.
Look it up.
INTERVIEWER: So what happened
afterwards?
JAMES SWIRSKY: At that point,
it was turning into this
thing, and Jim's music was
making it so much better.
LISANNE PAJOT: We applied for
some festivals and we were
working up towards a
festival deadline.
And we thought if we got into
any sort of film festival--
which really wasn't our
plan initially--
we'd get into a Canadian one.
Then we got rejected,
which really sucked.
JAMES SWIRSKY: Because we
thought, if we're going to get
into any upper-tier festival,
it'd be a Canadian one,
because they have home court
advantage and they have to
show so many Canadian films.
And so hopefully we're one
of the top five Canadian
documentaries that year.
And we weren't.
LISANNE PAJOT: We applied to two
festivals and we got into
one, but we didn't get
into the big one.
And so we were a little
disappointed.
But then a few weeks later, we
found out that we got into
Sundance, which sort of
changed everything.
Which was just such
a huge thing.
We just never thought that
this little film--
in our plan, you write
down your plan--
OK, make the movie,
get the great
composer, then go to Sundance.
JAMES SWIRSKY: Premiere
at Sundance.
LISANNE PAJOT: You don't
write that down.
JAMES SWIRSKY: Yeah.
LISANNE PAJOT: So that was sort
of a big thing for us.
INTERVIEWER: And that, you also
did something interesting
with distribution, right?
JAMES SWIRSKY: Yeah.
We went to Sundance and--
the whole process of making this
movie, we treated it very
pragmatic and very practical.
And we had our idea of DIY
distribution, like what would
happen if we got no distribution
deal or
anything like that.
We would go, we'll take it out
on tour, and then we'll
release it ourselves where we
can, and then we'll distribute
it online, and all this stuff.
So we had this really
base plan of what we
wanted to do ourselves.
And then once we got into
Sundance, things changed, and
they changed really quickly
and really dramatically.
But at the same time, they
didn't change for us.
But we got 1,000 emails that day
it was announced we were
in Sundance.
And then the next day, we got
like 800 emails, and then 600.
And it was just this crazy
overwhelming crush of
opportunity that you have
to kind of sift through.
And we went into Sundance
thinking, OK, well, let's
listen to absolutely
everything.
We have ideas of what we can do
and what would be good, but
we're new to everything.
So we thought, let's embrace
traditional distribution where
it makes sense, and do
what we want where it
doesn't make sense.
LISANNE PAJOT: So generally,
when people go to a big
festival like Sundance or
Cannes or the Toronto
International Film Festival, is
you go there and you show
your movie, and then you have
a sales agent who's like a
real estate agent, and then they
try to get all the buyers
really excited about your movie
and try to get them to
bid against each other so
they'll give you like a
million dollars in one night.
Well, that didn't
really happen.
And we weren't really
banking on it.
But we did get lots of interest,
and the film ended
up being optioned by HBO and
Scott Rudin to make into TV
series, a fictional TV series,
which was kind of insane.
Scott Rudin happens to be the
producer of "The Social
Network," which is bizarre.
INTERVIEWER: Karma for using
their score, right?
LISANNE PAJOT: I know.
As temp music.
And we got lots of offers and
lots of excitement, and we did
lots of interviews with, like,
German "Glamour." It was just
very weird.
But then we decided we didn't
want to sell it.
There wasn't--
everybody was saying that the
film wouldn't be able to come
out until the fall, and they'd
push it out theatrically, and
then they'd control
the digital.
And our worry was we had, at
this point, about 10,000
people that had pre-ordered
the movie, from
all over the world.
And so our concern was if we
put it out traditionally,
people wouldn't receive
it at the same time.
Because generally,
distribution happens per territory.
We were just learning
all this stuff.
And so we decided not to sell
it, and do it ourselves.
So we took the film
out on tour.
We did a tour across the States
with a partner, Adobe.
And then it went in theaters
in twelve centers, which we
booked ourselves, and
37 in Canada.
And then we put it out online
ourselves, on iTunes, Steam--
a big gaming platform--
and our own website, on
June 12 worldwide.
And that hadn't really
been done before
for a feature film.
And luckily, it worked out.
It was kind of stressful.
INTERVIEWER: Was this actually
the first movie on Steam?
LISANNE PAJOT: Yeah.
JAMES SWIRSKY: Yeah.
There was a short movie made by
couple Valve employees that
happened, I think, six
years ago or so.
But this is the first feature
film on Steam.
And it's been great.
It's absolutely the perfect
place for it.
It's sitting right next to
"Super Meat Boy" and "Braid"
and "World of Goo." And yeah,
it's just perfect.
LISANNE PAJOT: Through the
distribution part.
INTERVIEWER: And I guess
that brings us to--
what was the reaction from
people watching?
Because the interesting part
about this movie is that as
you mentioned, you could have
done it a number of different
ways, right?
You could have focused on the
technology or the history of
indie games, or like 15
different developers just kind
of chatting randomly.
And you decided to tell,
essentially, two, three
stories of three different
games, but not as much games
as people behind those
games, right?
And was this something that
surprised people who were
expecting something else?
And did you get different
reactions from people who
maybe are not gamers, and then
all of these hard-core people
who'd played all these games
before and they were like, we
wanted to know more about those
games, rather than about
the people?
LISANNE PAJOT: Yeah.
Yeah.
I think the film ended up
turning into something really
strong, in part because we
focused on it, but also the
guys that we focused on in the
film are really generous with
their thoughts.
And they were really generous
with us and with the audience,
in terms of how vulnerable
they are at times.
Like, it's a stressful movie.
We were filming people at the
most stressful points in their
lives, and little did we know
it would get so stressful.
And I think people bizarrely
connect with that.
And so no matter whether you're
a gamer or you're--
that--
he's a little stressed there.
INTERVIEWER: We have more.
LISANNE PAJOT: No matter whether
you're a gamer or a
developer or just a maker, we
related to it, so we hoped
other people would
relate to it to.
And people really connect with
their stories because they
share so much, and they're so
much themselves in the film,
in these sort of super
intense moments.
And so it sort of transcended
beyond just people that were
into gaming.
And we wanted that, but
we were really sort of
surprised by that.
JAMES SWIRSKY: And every
screening, there's always--
we do Q&As and stuff
like that.
There's always someone--
it's usually like a woman in
her '40s or '50s that was
brought there by a son or just
kind of brought there because
she likes documentaries
or something.
But she'll ask a question,
but the
question's more like a statement.
And she's just--
and we've gotten this
four or five times.
And it's always something to
the effect of, you know, I
don't play games, I don't like
games, I never picked up a
controller, but games are
kind of like art, right?
And it was like this
revelation to her.
And that's this kind of dream
reaction that we can hope for.
And we've gotten that over and
over again, just people that
have never really thought about
games in this way-- and
that's fine, because it's
not part of their lives.
There's no reason for them to
really consider games as
something more than just these
little playthings.
But when we do get those people
into the theater and
they do actually change their
opinion of games in some
little way--
they're not going out and
buying an Xbox or
anything like that.
But it's just that they're a
little more thoughtful towards
games, which is a huge victory,
an amazing victory.
We got a lot of that.
INTERVIEWER: Do you think
anybody who watched this movie
decided that they're going to
go indie, like, right now.
LISANNE PAJOT: It's funny.
We were talking about
this earlier.
And I think a lot of programming
works this way--
you see yourself, people
identify with certain
characters in the film, or
read in what they want.
It's sort of like a personality
test, in a way.
So if you walk out of this film
thinking, oh yeah, I want
to make a game, that
means that you're a
little bit of an idealist.
And that's wonderful.
Or if you walk away and be like,
ugh, I don't want to
become independent at all.
People read into their
own things.
So when we were on tour, we had
a lot of people come up.
And in particular, we were
showing in Chicago and this
girlfriend of a guy said, hey,
my boyfriend watched movie and
he quit his job and he's
living with me now.
JAMES SWIRSKY: So, thanks.
LISANNE PAJOT: And he's
doing a Kickstarter.
You should tweet about it.
INTERVIEWER: Here's
your free DVD.
Sorry.
LISANNE PAJOT: Sorry.
Yeah.
So the reactions have been a lot
of wonderful things, and
really beyond what
we ever thought.
It's weird that 13-year-old,
12-year-old kids are watching
a documentary.
We get a lot of emails from
kids saying that they are
really excited by this, or
they make a video of
themselves on YouTube reviewing
it at 12 o'clock at
night in their bedrooms so
their parents can't hear.
It's bizarre to see the way that
the people in the film
have touched so many people.
And it's about making games,
so it's kind of weird.
INTERVIEWER: So let's open
it up for questions.
I have the number
of them here.
Crazy technology of people
asking remotely.
But I wonder if anybody in the
audience has any questions.
And I guess we should repeat the
question so I don't know
if you want me to do that.
LISANNE PAJOT: So how did we
choose to characterize people?
Hm.
I don't know.
I think we were capturing people
at an elevated time.
So everything is a little more
high stakes than usual.
I would say that all the people
in the film, in their
day-to-day now, after this
experience has happened, are
much more low-key versions
of themselves.
JAMES SWIRSKY: Yeah.
And actually Phil joined us for
a few Q&As and was asked
very similar questions.
And he says, that's what I was
like then, in that moment.
We literally were filming
these people at the most
stressful periods of their
lives, and this
kind of crazed thing.
And a lot of people, I think,
go through similar periods,
but there's never a camera crew
there and then asking you
to talk through what's
going on your mind.
And so it's a small segment of
their lives, which is where
the story revolves around.
But yeah, it's not completely,
absolutely the full picture.
LISANNE PAJOT: Yeah.
Yeah.
So we didn't get to add here.
So the game "Fez"
did come out.
It came out on Friday the 13th
in April, and it did really
well on Xbox.
And Phil's doing great.
He's in Montreal.
He's creating lots of
new things now.
He has a girlfriend,
which is awesome.
And we did film an epilogue with
him, but we didn't get
him when he was releasing the
game because we were already
on tour with the film, which
killed us, because he was with
his new girlfriend in Nashville
and we were in
Chicago or something.
JAMES SWIRSKY: I wanted
to be there so bad.
Yeah.
LISANNE PAJOT: So we
did film with him.
We filmed with him in Montreal
after the game had actually
finished in December.
He finished in December.
And then we caught up with him
at the Game Developers
Conference this year, where you
won the top award, which
was a big validation for him.
So he won the Seamus McNally
award, which is the biggest
award you can get in
independent gaming.
So we followed him
through that day.
JAMES SWIRSKY: Yeah.
How it came about was like, we
always thought, wouldn't it be
great if we were on Steam?
And we actually introduced to
the Steam folks through Ron
Carmel, "World of Goo," and
then also Edmund McMillen,
who's in the movie.
And they just kind
of hooked us up.
And then it was about
eight months of
arm-twisting, in a way.
Like subtle arm-twisting.
LISANNE PAJOT: Yeah, eventually
we flew down to
Seattle, and we said, OK, we
know that you don't do with
movies, but we'll make it
into an app so it's
easy for your system.
And it will be moderately
interactive, but not really.
And we'll show it to you.
So we went down and we showed
them, and they had a really
great reaction to the film.
And I think it's sort of
an experiment for them.
Because what's interesting is if
you're on Steam, and let's
say, your friend is watching
"Indie Game, the Movie." It'll
say, "Playing 'Indie Game, the
Movie.'" They're not set up
for movies right now.
This is sort of a
big exception.
But it's been incredible.
Steam has been the strongest
platform for this film,
numbers-wise.
And they're really merchandised
really well.
They know how to do online sales
and all these things
that the movies areas-- like,
we're on Amazon and all these
different places-- they don't
do those things yet.
These guys know how to
do sales and stuff.
So we basically follow, in real
time, "Super Meat Boy."
Oh, so the question was, why
are they all successes?
JAMES SWIRSKY: Was
that planned?
LISANNE PAJOT: Yeah,
was that planned?
No.
We filmed with a lot of
developers, but they were all
interviews, and nobody was
in the moment developing.
And the only two teams that were
in the moment developing
that we followed were "Super
Meat Boy" and "Fez."
When we caught up with Phil,
we weren't sure if he was
going to finish at all.
He was at a point
where he was--
you see him halfway through the
movie saying, I don't know
what I'm going to do.
And nobody knew how well "Super
Meat Boy" would do.
So it was really just by
chance that we started
following them, that it ended
up being successful.
JAMES SWIRSKY: Like "Super Meat
Boy" had buzz, and that's
how they got on our radar,
and then we did
our research on them.
But they didn't have, like,
"you're going to sell million
copies" buzz, and "be game of
the year" type of thing.
And so when you see it, in the
movie, when all the reviews
are rolling in, Edmund is
genuinely surprised at all
these things.
No one is hating this game.
Like no one is saying horrible
things about it.
And I guess he was
half-expecting that, but they
were just these amazing,
huge successes.
And of course, that's not
every indie game.
We know that for sure, and we're
not trying to say that.
But it's just the stories
of these games.
Yeah.
So it was kind of--
LISANNE PAJOT: That we happened
to hook up with a
year and a half before they
became successes.
JAMES SWIRSKY: Yeah.
LISANNE PAJOT: We
did interview--
in terms of, we had a few
talking-head expert types.
We did interview women, and
we got comments from them.
But it just turns out that the
people that we talked to
didn't say things that connected
in a way that we
needed to explain
what we wanted.
Like, we could have shoehorned
a woman into the film as an
expert, just to have a woman,
but they didn't say the things
that we needed them to say.
JAMES SWIRSKY: And I think--
at one point, it was going to
be this essay-type film with
this narrative back-end, or
narrative arc, being the
structure and then these little
vignettes happening.
And we did capture woman
interviews for those pieces,
but then as things evolved and
the stories of "Fez" and
"Super Meat Boy" became these
more involved things that
demanded more time in the film,
it pushed out all these
vignette pieces that we thought
would be there.
We thought we'd have about
five or six vignettes.
LISANNE PAJOT: And the women
that we spoke to were talking
in past tense about the games
that they had made.
So it didn't connect
into the story.
It was more just a function
of story than it was any
deliberate choice of having all
white men in the movie.
JAMES SWIRSKY: Who are
making platformers.
All white men making
platformers.
LISANNE PAJOT: All making
That wasn't--
INTERVIEWER: High concept
platformers.
JAMES SWIRSKY: Yeah.
LISANNE PAJOT: Yeah.
Renault?
Yeah.
We did interview him,
and we included him.
Yeah.
There wasn't a specific
reason.
He wasn't at PAX.
So he was there during the
beginning of it, and we
include a little bit from
that section, that trip.
But he didn't appear at PAX
until the third day.
And so that was sort of a
story problem as well.
Because he didn't show up as
much later in the film and
wasn't present later in the
film, we couldn't show more of
him in the beginning of the
film, because you'd wonder
where he was later.
It's sort of a story thing.
JAMES SWIRSKY: Yeah.
And also one of the main theses
of the film is kind of
games as personal expression.
That's one of the sub-theses.
And so we were really drawn to
people who are making games
that are a reflection
of themselves.
And Phil, as the designer, kind
of spoke more to that.
Renault definitely, obviously
has huge influence in the
game, and his fingerprints
are all over that game.
But it just felt more natural
for what we were pursuing to
just concentrate on
those four guys.
INTERVIEWER: On that note, did
you try to reach out to Phil
Fish's partner, that's like all
pixelated a couple times,
but no dialogue or monologue,
whatsoever.
LISANNE PAJOT: That was a hugely
surprising storyline,
sub-storyline, that happened.
We arrived in Boston
thinking that--
we knew Phil would be nervous
about showing the game for the
first time in four years at PAX,
but we didn't know about
that until we arrived.
And it was sort of taking us by
surprise, what was happening.
JAMES SWIRSKY: Yeah, so we
filmed that lobby scene, and
we thought it wouldn't end up
making it in the film, but we
had to show it, because it ended
up completely clouding
Phil's reaction to PAX.
Like all of a sudden, you just
have this guy who's really
depressed at PAX for no reason,
or just really, really
super-stressed out and you
don't want know why.
So we ended up including it, and
yeah, we tried to tell the
story from the point of
view of the creators.
You know, it's the story of
making "Fez" and what Phil's
going through.
And we thought if we went into
this dissolution of a
partnership thing and told the
whole story of that, it would
be this we off-branch and take
the movie into a place that is
further removed from making
this game and pouring
everything you have
into this game.
So yeah, we didn't really
pursue that.
No.
I think it was the most
interesting aspect and
surprising story about
post-release,
that we came across.
It was actually this
through-line of everyone who
had these wonderful successes,
they go through this kind of
postpartum depression
of sorts.
And John's was the most dramatic
and surprising.
And we thought that it kind of
dovetailed really nicely with
the other two stories we were
pursuing, because with "Fez,"
you have a game that's kind of
in development, and will they
make it or won't they make it?
With "Meat Boy," you have a game
that's fully developed
and released, and so
you get to see
that part of the process.
And then with John, it fit
really nicely, thematically,
to have what happens
after release.
And so it predicts into the
future what's in store for
Edmund and Tommy, in some way.
Of course, it's a very extreme
example of that.
But it just seemed like a great
take on that section of
the process, and just dovetailed
quite nicely.
And we think it shows a side
of John that is really
surprising.
Like, I think he has an internet
persona, and I hope
this kind of goes against that
internet persona a little bit.
That's a small, light
question.
INTERVIEWER: The question is,
why do indie games matter?
LISANNE PAJOT: What was
interesting to us about
pursuing independent games was
that it was just people doing
something different with a
medium that you're familiar
with in a certain way.
So these are people that are
pushing that in a different
direction and exploring smaller
personal things in the
same way that you would have
seen with independent film in
the '90s or the '70s, people
using a medium in a different
way to tell different stories.
And that was
compelling to Us.
It was also compelling to us
because these people, the
people that we follow-- and
maybe we're like this, too--
are kind of obsessive.
And I think it was just a neat
way for us to look at creative
obsession and that creative
process through these artists,
as opposed to other kinds
of artists like poets or
filmmakers or whatever.
I think we were interested in
looking at those ideas through
these people.
JAMES SWIRSKY: Yeah.
I agree with all that.
LISANNE PAJOT: That's why it
mattered to us, rather.
JAMES SWIRSKY: Yeah.
INTERVIEWER: So actually, on
that note, a lot of the things
you portrayed in movie, like the
agony of creation or the
sacrifices you make and that
kind of vulnerability, or
like, yourself, you put in it.
Those are universal, right?
And I think that's why a lot of
people reacted to the movie
the way they did, even if
they never played games.
I'm curious if there are any
parallels between those things
that we saw and your
own adventure
in making it a movie.
Any kind of, you know--
LISANNE PAJOT: Totally.
JAMES SWIRSKY: Oh, yeah.
LISANNE PAJOT: We went crazy
this past two years.
It's been up and down, like
a lot of the same things.
Like the idea of putting
yourself out there
through your work.
When this went out there, I
thought, what is everyone
going to say?
We value certain things, and
by choosing these things in
the film, they're going
to see what I value.
That was sort of a thing.
And having it all over the
internet, and people on
YouTube saying awful things.
JAMES SWIRSKY: And great things,
but just like in the
movie, you'll have 1,000
positive comments and then
you'll have two or three
negative ones, and all you pay
attention to is the negative.
It seemed like every emotional
arc in this movie, we went
through making it.
It felt, in many ways, that we
were filming ourselves six
months into the future, although
we had no idea of
knowing it.
But it was like, we're filming
Tommy crunching
for his Xbox deadline.
And then fast-forward six
months, and we're crunching to
hit this festival deadline.
And then we lose all our
renders the day before.
And it's just like
all these things.
LISANNE PAJOT: We're fixing bugs
in the Steam app up until
the minute that it goes live.
It was very, it was remarkably
similar.
And we didn't realize that
when we were making it.
INTERVIEWER: I found this photo,
and I think this is
your photo, but correct
me if I'm wrong.
That was pretty funny.
[LAUGHTER]
INTERVIEWER: I think someone
needs to make a movie about
this thing.
[LAUGHTER]
LISANNE PAJOT: Yeah, so we've
been both making videos and
television for about 10 years.
I started--
I was really lucky.
I got a job at the Canadian
Broadcasting Corporation, and
I worked in television, in
television news, and then
worked into lifestyle
television,
like gardening shows.
And then I ended up
in documentaries.
And so I was sort of working
in documentaries, and James
has a slightly different
background.
JAMES SWIRSKY: Yeah.
I went to university
and I took--
when you want to be a filmmaker
in Winnipeg,
Manitoba, it seems like a
silly thing to pursue.
So when I went to university,
I took business, and then I
took film studies on the side.
And if you're in Canada and you
want to go into film, you
either go to Vancouver
or you go to Toronto.
So I went to Vancouver, trying
to break into film.
And I couldn't get a job at all,
so I took a good job as a
games tester for Electronic
Arts.
And I spent two years there.
And it was the best and worst
job I've ever had in my life.
And it actually turned me
off games for a while.
I hadn't touched games for,
like, eight years, until
actually discovering
indie games.
That kind of brought
me back to games.
But I'm getting off-topic.
So shortly after that, I moved
back to Winnipeg, and someone
offered me money to do a high
school graduation, and
videotape it.
And so I was, like, oh,
yeah, that's awesome.
I'll do that.
And then it was just like this
thing clicked in my head.
I was like, oh, people will
pay me money to do
things with my camera.
And so that turned into
another high school
graduation, which turned into a
wedding, which turned into a
commercial, and then it created
this 10 years of doing
commercial corporate work
that grew and got more
ambitious with time.
LISANNE PAJOT: Eventually I left
CBC and started working
with him on commercials.
And so we were doing commercials
in Canada.
It was going really well.
We'd worked up to a point where
we had, like, national
clothing retailers.
It was like, whoa.
JAMES SWIRSKY: Yeah, we were
finally getting the jobs and
gigs that we wanted, the
size and the budgets
and all that stuff.
And it was literally--
in Canada, there's a lot of RFP
lists, and we were finally
on the rarefied lists,
the ones you
really want to get onto.
And then we decided
to make this.
We kind of naively thought that
we could make this in
about a year, and not only will
it take a year, but we
can take breaks and knock off a
commercial gig for cash flow
and stuff like that.
And that didn't happen at all.
It was like "Indie Game,"
24/7, for the
last 2 and 1/2 years.
That just kind of took
over our lives.
But all though that period,
we've kind of been doing
everything, like shooting,
editing, motion graphics.
And it just always worked for
the projects that we were on.
And so we just kind of naively
took that thinking into "Indie
Game," thinking that this
would just be like 18
five-minute videos, that's
all we need to do.
That type of effort.
And it wasn't, at all.
But we learned a lot of lessons
doing it, and I think
we're better for it.
But I think our naivete kind
of worked in our favor,
because had we known, we
might not have done it.
INTERVIEWER: I have online
question that's maybe the
[INAUDIBLE]
a little bit.
Did you miss any great moments
while filming?
Did you have to restage
anything?
LISANNE PAJOT: No.
JAMES SWIRSKY: No.
LISANNE PAJOT: We didn't restage
anything, but there
was a lot of things that could
have happened that could have
had us not capture
certain things.
Like for instance, at the end
of the film, Edmund has this
wonderful postmortem interview,
reflecting on the
experience, and it would've been
much more difficult if he
had shaved.
He was about to shave
off his beard.
JAMES SWIRSKY: Oh, yeah, yeah.
Well, basically, Edmund just
watched some reviews, and it
was at the end of his four days
of release of "Super Meat
Boy." And I went to the hotel to
offload footage and kind of
gave Edmund and Danielle
some alone time.
And Edmund was this close
to shaving for the final
interview, which would have
completely screwed up
everything.
And Danielle stopped him from
doing it-- not because she
thought it would be bad for the
movie, but she thought it
might be something that they
want to get for the movie.
But thank God that she stopped
him, because otherwise we
would have this weird--
it would've been a title
card. "Edmund shaved."
INTERVIEWER: Or,
you know, CGI.
LISANNE PAJOT: Yeah.
JAMES SWIRSKY: Yeah, or CGI.
LISANNE PAJOT: Facial hair
changes actually sort of are
kind of a timeline
in the movie.
And so that would have screwed
up a little bit.
LISANNE PAJOT: Yeah.
Yeah.
You can kind of like see their
state, their mental and
emotional states as through
their facial hair.
And yeah.
INTERVIEWER: What's next, and
Humble Bundle, maybe?
JAMES SWIRSKY: Yeah.
Well, because we're
self-releasing, we're still on
this thing.
We're probably going to
be on it for about
another five, six months.
And I've been underestimating
everything all throughout this
thing, so it's probably--
LISANNE PAJOT: When he says
five, six months,
just think a year.
JAMES SWIRSKY: A year.
Yeah.
So we're going to--
we hope to actually be starting
something new.
We have three ideas and we're
pursuing all three of them.
We're going to kind of
see what sticks.
And we hope to start filming
in May/June of next year.
LISANNE PAJOT: Watch for
the Kickstarter.
JAMES SWIRSKY: Yeah.
And Humble Bundle would
be awesome.
I think that would be cool.
They haven't done movies yet,
but Steam hasn't done movies.
Oh, the Cookie, right?
LISANNE PAJOT: Cookie.
JAMES SWIRSKY: Yeah,
yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Those guys are awesome, and we
love what they're doing, and
we would love to do
it with them.
INTERVIEWER: So in the process
of researching this, I just
want to show this picture
because I think it's the most
awesome thing ever, and
I kind of want to
hear the back story.
So there's Will Arnett,
and there's a
Power Glove, and Christmas.
So it's almost too much.
But I want to know
what this is.
LISANNE PAJOT: This
was all his idea.
JAMES SWIRSKY: Yeah.
There was a local radio station
in Winnipeg, and Will
Arnett does awesome charity
work, and he was there with
the United Way of Winnipeg and
they were launching this
fantastic thing, where they
were giving Jets season
tickets to sick kids.
And really awesome stuff.
And he was in town promoting
that, and the radio station
had this contest.
LISANNE PAJOT: Like, get your
office together to take a
photo with Will Arnett.
But he, like, staged it.
JAMES SWIRSKY: Well, yeah.
It was supposed to be--
basically, yeah, highest bidder
gets their Christmas
card with Will Arnett.
And you can send it off--
LISANNE PAJOT: Your company
Christmas card.
JAMES SWIRSKY: Your company
Christmas card, and you can
send it off to all your
customers and stuff like that.
And yeah, so I bid,
and we won.
And these are the only marketing
dollars we ever
spent for the movie.
And so I think he was kind of
expecting just to kind of go
and do like, hey, how
are you, and do a
meet-and-greet type of thing.
And I had plans, and so I
directed the photoshoot.
[LAUGHTER]
JAMES SWIRSKY: I was, like, no,
we want you put on this
red sweater.
Which he didn't want to do,
which was understandable,
because it was kind of gross,
and he was looked
very good at the time.
So he just kind of hung it on
his shoulder, and I'm like,
OK, and you have this present,
and it's to be a
Power Glove in it.
And he didn't really know what
a Power Glove was, but he was
really game and he was
really nice about it.
And you open it, and we're going
to be proud parents,
then you'll put it on.
And we'll take photos throughout
the whole thing.
And then we turned it into this
album art, and that was
our Christmas card for that.
And yeah.
He was awesome throughout
the whole thing.
INTERVIEWER: On that
note, yeah.
I'm curious--
we have five minutes, so maybe
one or two more questions.
JAMES SWIRSKY: Yeah, totally.
INTERVIEWER: I'm curious about
the kind of iconic Super
Nintendo controller kind of
hanging there in the-- well,
everywhere, pretty much.
Is there any story
behind that?
LISANNE PAJOT: Yeah.
INTERVIEWER: And why Super
Nintendo, and not, like, I
don't know--
LISANNE PAJOT: NES.
Yeah.
We've gotten that
question before?
INTERVIEWER: Atari joystick?
LISANNE PAJOT: Atari.
It was actually the first
thing we ever shot.
We went to breakfast one day and
we were talking about this
idea of doing a film about
game design and game
development and whatever.
And then we sort of left, and
we were like, yeah, yeah, I
think we'll start.
JAMES SWIRSKY: This was about
four or five months before we
actually even decided
to do the movie.
LISANNE PAJOT: So we were just
sort of talking about it, and
walked outside in a back alley,
and there hanging was a
Super Nintendo controller
from the sky.
And so we shot it.
And we just shot it as like-- it
was like a little bit of a
sign, in a way--
not really realizing what
we'd use it for.
Just, oh, that's kind
of interesting.
Incidentally, there was an NES
controller just down the road.
JAMES SWIRSKY: But it wasn't
as artfully hanging.
Like it was there, but it the
composition wasn't good.
LISANNE PAJOT: This is
an area in Winnipeg
that's called Wolseley.
It's kind of artsy.
And so there's just random
things hanging from the sky.
And so we did our first
Kickstarter in May 2010, and
we needed a little bit of video
to put on the front of
it, for whatever reason.
And we included this video, and
we put "Indie Game, the
Movie" beside the controller.
And that ended up being the
Vimeo tab, and that went
everywhere.
We just didn't realize.
And so that turned into the
image, just through Google
search, essentially ended
up being the main
image for the movie.
And it just sort of stuck.
And so we didn't
fight with it.
We just kind of left it.
JAMES SWIRSKY: And this
is kind of like--
"Indie Game, the Movie," was
also a working title.
We thought at some point we'd
come up with something much
more evocative.
LISANNE PAJOT: And better.
JAMES SWIRSKY: Something
better than that.
But it was kind of like one of
the downsides to communicating
from day one-- even before day
one, actually, of shooting--
is that your marketing your film
and you're talking your
film, but you're kind of also
laying all this groundwork.
And we just thought of it from
an audience-building
perspective, and we weren't
really thinking about--
we just thought, we can change
the title and morph the image
of the movie as we need, and it
just got picked up so much
more, so much earlier than
we thought, that we felt
compelled to stick with it.
And we liked it, too, and we
liked that you could kind of
read into the image and what it
means, and all that stuff.
But originally, it just started
as a pretty picture in
front of our Kickstarter
campaign.
And we just ran with it.
But yeah, it's a neat lesson to
learn about communication,
and being so open so early.
I wouldn't ever dissuade anybody
from doing that, but
it's just something that I would
consider a little more
for our next project.
INTERVIEWER: So I think that
last question, you learned a
lot about making games, making
indie games, from the movie.
I was curious if you could share
one piece of advice, if
you want to go and start
making a documentary.
I'm kind of selfishly asking,
because I'm curious, but I
hope other people are too.
Is there one thing that learned
that had no idea
before that would be important,
that you can pass
on to other people.
LISANNE PAJOT: Well, we shot
about 300 hours, but I wish we
would have shot more.
So just never turn
the camera off.
That would be my advice.
JAMES SWIRSKY: Yeah, because
there are so many moments in
the movie that are actual
beautiful moments, really
strong moments in the movie,
that we were this close to
turning the camera off, and then
this magic just happened.
And sometimes, even when the
magic's happening, you don't
really realize it, that it's
happening and that it'll end
up in the movie.
Like Danielle crying.
There's this one scene where
Edmund reads a review, and
then Danielle kind of breaks
down into tears.
And that was something, that
was one of those instances
where I was like this close to
stopping record, and actually
packing up and leaving
for the night.
And then this beautiful
stuff happens.
Same thing, when she's talking
about the cats.
I thought that was a
throwaway piece.
I thought, it's a cute moment,
but it really worked really,
really well to kind of add a
little bit of levity right
when you needed it.
Yeah, so never stop filming.
And also, I would say to people
out there, I know a lot
of other filmmakers that wait
for everything to be perfect.
They wait until they have the
perfect script and that they
have all their budget and that
they have the perfect camera
that they want, or they're
waiting for the next camera to
come out, and all these things
that can really just act as
these hurdles towards your
actually getting out there and
making something.
Had we waited for situations to
be perfect for this movie,
we probably wouldn't
have made it.
And so I'm a big fan of just
going out there and doing it.
And maybe you won't do the job
that you wanted to, but at
least you got there and you made
something, and you can
build on that.
And the next thing will be
better, because you'll be
learning through actual doing.
But a lot of people, yeah, they
just kind of wait until
everything's absolutely
perfect.
And it very rarely
ever, ever is.
INTERVIEWER: Right.
Well, on that note,
I suppose--
yeah, thank you so
much for coming.
Again, it's a great movie.
For those two people in the
audience who haven't seen it,
please do, or see it again.
Thanks for coming.
And if you want to stick around,
we actually have a
16-inch version of
"Cybervision." Other than
that, thank you so much.
LISANNE PAJOT: Guard
your [INAUDIBLE].
JAMES SWIRSKY: Thanks
for having us.
[APPLAUSE]